I think that everyone in the world could
be a math person if they wanted to.
The key word though I want to say is if
they wanted to.
That said,
I do think that everyone in America
could benefit from having that matt bath
mathematical backgrounds in reasoning
just to help everyone make very good
decisions.
And here I'm distinguishing already
between math as people usually conceive
of it and decision making and analysis,
which is actually what I think math is.
So for example,
I don't think that being a math person
means that you can recite the formulas
between signs,
co-signs tangents and to use logarithms
and exponentials interchangeably.
That's not necessarily what I think
everyone should try to concentrate to
understand.
The main things to concentrate to
understand are the mathematical
principles of reasoning.
But let me go back to these signs.
Co-Signs and,
and,
and logarithms.
Well actually if they do have value,
what they are is that they are ways to
show you how these basic building blocks
of reasoning can be used to deduce
surprising things or difficult things.
In some sense.
They're like the historical coverages of
the triumphs of mathematics,
so one cannot just talk abstractly
about,
yes,
let's,
let's talk about mathematical logic.
It's actually quite useful to have case
studies or stories which are,
which are these,
these famous theorems now I actually
think that these are accessible to
everyone.
I think that actually one reason
mathematics is difficult to understand.
It's actually because of that network of
prerequisites.
You see math is one of these strange
subjects for which the concepts are
chained in sequences of dependencies.
When you have long chains,
there are very few starting points.
Very few things I need to memorize.
I don't need to memorize,
for example,
all these things in history such as when
was the war of 1812 well actually I know
that one because that's a matter of
fact.
It was 1812 but I can't tell you a lot
of other facts which are just purely
memorized in mathematics.
You are very few that you memorize and
the rest you did use as you go through
and this chain of deductions is actually
what's critical.
Now,
let me contrast that with other
subjects.
Like say history.
History doesn't have this long chain.
In fact,
if you fully understand the war of 1812
that's great and it is true that that
will influence perhaps your
understanding later of the women's
movement.
But it won't be as absolutely
prerequisite in the sense that if you
think about the concepts,
I actually think that history has more
concepts than mathematics.
It's just that they're spread out
broader and they don't depend on each
other as strongly.
So for example,
if you miss a week,
you will miss the understanding of one
unit,
but that won't,
that won't stop you from understanding
all of the rest of the components.
So that's actually the difference
between math and other subjects.
In my head,
math has fewer concepts,
but they're chained deeper.
And because of the way that we usually
learn,
when you have deep chains,
it's very fragile because you're gonna
lose anyone link meeting.
If you miss a few concepts along the
chain,
you can actually be completely lost.
If,
for example,
you're sick a week or if your mind is
somewhere else for a week,
you might make a hole in your
prerequisites.
And the way that education often works
where it's almost like riding a train
from a beginning to an end.
Well,
it's such that if you have a whole
summer and your track,
the train is not going to pass that
hole.
Now I think that the way to help to
address this is to provide a way for
everyone to learn at their own pace and
in fact a fill in the holes whenever
they are sensed.
And I actually feel like if everyone was
able to pick up every one of those
prerequisites as necessary,
filling in any gaps they have,
mathematics would change from being the
hardest subject to the easiest subject.
I think everyone's a math person and all
that one has to do is to go through the
chain and fill in all the gaps and
you'll understand it easier,
more better than all the other subjects.
Actually.